et l'allemagne peut également être le
modèle pour bon nombre de pays européens
y compris pour la france y a pas eu de
débat populiste sur l'immigration des
partis anti-système qui recule en
dessous des 15 % à contre courant de ce
qui se passe dans le reste de l'union
européenne
quelle est la recette de votre
démocratie d alfred je pensais surtout
qu'il ya eu un vrai débat entre les
principaux partis les verts les les
social démocrates et les conservateurs
un vrai une vraie lutte pour la
succession de en gala merkel et je pense
et ce débat qui a ramené une une bonne
partie des allemands ou au centre
politique et de supporter à la fin des
des partis plus ou moins centristes que
sont tous les droits les droits grands
partis alors en fait toute l'europe a
encore les yeux tournés cette semaine à
vers berlin et se demande si comme en
2017 il faudra cinq six mois pour
accoucher dans la douleur d'une
coalition c'est à dire que l'allemagne
pourrait être en quelque sorte en
hibernation
politique et en paralysie européenne en
quelque sorte alors c'est à nouveau les
allemands qui décideront mais c'est vrai
que c'est un processus selon
transparent aussi et ça je trouve que
c'est remarquable qui fait suite à une
campagne qui c'est vrai nom a pas
beaucoup parlé d'europe c'est un peu
dommage mais a fait dialoguer les partis
de gouvernement
et ça c'est très différent de ce qui se
passe actuellement en france sont les
extrêmes qui occupe le paysage
médiatique donc ça c'est fort parce que
ça ça permet quand même de deux traités
entre gens responsables ou
potentiellement en charge avec une
obligation de réalisme de propositions
concrètes en prise avec avec la
population
[Musique]